here's a voicemail at 2192 david p
that really doesn't make a lot of sense
to me it's one of these where someone is
projecting on to me something
i guess from somewhere else this time
about dr fauci take a listen to this
david i'm not really sure why you're
still cheerleading anthony fauci at this
point it's pretty clear from all the
news coming out recently that the man is
a liar and a proven liar he clearly knew
that this virus came from more than just
a natural means
look into the emails released
they're real
i think he should be fired and he should
be ashamed of himself
he was never a very good
person at his position dealing with
epidemics or pandemics so listen first
of all
nothing has been proven
about the origins of the virus other
than what we currently know which is it
seems to have come from animals
and jumped to humans once if and when we
have proof of something other than that
i will talk about it in terms of
cheerleading anthony fauci i don't know
that you've really seen my show i don't
really care about dr fauci as an
individual what i do know is that the
smear campaigns against him and his
motives
are not based in evidence or fact and i
am a cheerleader for the best empirical
knowledge that we have at the time
that's what you can always count on on
this program
what do we know
based on actual studies right now that's
what you are going to get from me not
cheerleading of individuals or anything
like it we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about the joe
rogan response to the spotify
dust up we're going to talk about the
california universal health care bill
it's dead without even a vote
how we'll talk about it and we will also
talk about the fifth new york prosecutor
who has now declined to file sexual
harassment charges against the former
governor andrew cuomo all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com get instant
access and i will see you then